some positive news for Jay Lennon
absolutely and it comes straight from
his longtime friend Tim Allen
good
car magazines
we did some jokes which is what we do we
commiserated he was working on a car
when he was underneath the car and a
fire began how does this place look the
space looks great it did it did look all
that good to begin with so this is no
he's going with the George Clooney look
you're going to be surprised he's
handsome and he's happy and the
hospital's doing a great job taking care
of him Tim was cracking jokes after
visiting Jay at the Grossman Burn Center
where the talk show host is recovering
from third degree burns these two go way
back to the 80s and their early days on
the stand-up circuit I'm older than him
so I was a couple years ahead of him so
I was kind of like playing the clubs and
then when Tim was it was the most
expensive
like that I go well what's your name
Timmy you know he does a pretty good you
I do it on time to Tim how you doing
Jessica come on it doesn't sound like me
at all it sounds like the Chipmunks also
recovering today Al Roker who was
hospitalized for blood clots in his leg
and lungs it's hard to slow down now but
he's on the mend and he's on the way
there the 68 year old weather anchor
who's been absent from The Today Show
for two weeks posted this pic from the
hospital and wrote after some medical
whack-a-mole I am so fortunate to be
getting terrific Medical Care As for
next week's Thanksgiving Day Parade the
parade is back Al's been covering the
spectacle since 1995 and NBC is still
promoting him as one of the co-hosts of
course Al's been open about his health
struggles he lost more than 100 pounds
after gastric bypass and back in 2020 he
successfully underwent surgery for
prostate cancer good news is we caught
it early not great news is that it's a
little aggressive caught that early and
you know we're so far so good
[Music]